following the tragic news of Kobe
Bryant's death in a helicopter crash on
Sunday TMZ reports Kobe's daughter
Gianna was also on board the private
chopper which went down around the LA
neighborhood of Calabasas she was just
13 years old the NBA legend and his
daughter were on their way to the momba
Academy for a basketball practice when
the crash occurred the Academy is
located in the neighboring town Thousand
Oaks
Gianna arising basketball star herself
was often spotted sitting courtside at
the lakers games with her famous dad
most recently in December in January
Kobe shared this video of Gianna on the
court
writing gg getting better every day when
et caught up with Kobe in 2018 he opened
up about coaching his daughter school
basketball team after retiring from the
NBA in 2016 well it's been fun I mean
they're doing really well we've been
working together for a year and a half
and they've improved tremendously in
that time and I got a group of great
parents a group of really really
intelligent hard-working girls and you
know they're all seventh graders and
they're all you know 12 years old but
they've been playing so well they played
eighth and ninth grade and you know
they've been went into ornaments but the
most important thing is that they've
been improved and it just keep getting
better and they love doing it love being
around each other and Gianna's pretty
pretty easy to coach a man we haven't
had any issues of dad daughter sort of
thing I mean she's like she's very
competitive and and she's a hard worker
so it has it haven't been any any issues
with that and in 2019
Kobe opened up to ESPN about his
coaching style just about learning
and went up what I've learned is like
the most important thing for kids at
that age is it try to through curiosity
Coby and Vanessa shared three other
daughters as well Natalia 17 Bianca
three and Capri seven months stick with
ET as we'll be tracking this developing
story
[Music]